this Festival is a  spiritual poem for filmmakers and the  Art of Cinema particularly important now  when Cinema is devalued demeaned  um  belittled from all sides  not necessarily the business side but  certainly the art  and since the 80s has been you know a  focus on numbers  that is uh and it's kind of repulsive  it's like of course the cost of a movie  is one thing I understand the film costs  certain amount they expect to at least  get the amount back plus again but the  emphasis is now on numbers cost the  opening weekend how much you made in USA  how much you made in England how much  you made in Keisha how much you made in  the entire world  um how many views it got as a filmmaker  and as a person who  can't imagine life without Cinema  you never responded really insulting